Emmanuel Macron a donné une interview
d’après deux heures à Hugo décrypte sur
sa chaîne Youtube et bien nous voulons
débriefer de cette interview on va
parler de ce qui s'est dit lors de cette
interview et pour en parler je suis avec
Sophie de Tarlet bonjour Sophie bonjour
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
rédactrice en chef au Figaro étudiant
donc c'est des sujets que vous couvrez
que le président
très long enfin très long ça a été entre
toi très dense et avec beaucoup de
sujets qui ont été
dont on a parlé oui tout à fait un
entretien près de deux heures comme vous
le disiez et puis avec des sujets
c'est hétéroclite finalement je pensais
que ce qu'on allait plutôt se concentrer
sur
sur les jeunes sur le bac etc et en fait
pas du tout en fait commencer par le
bien sûr le sujet qui m'a étonné quand
même au début la dépression chez les
jeunes à la santé mentale et le manque
de professionnel pour accompagner les
jeunes
un sujet j'étais c'est vrai qu'on en
parlait beaucoup beaucoup plus pendant
le la crise du covid la santé mentale
c'est un sujet qui n'avait pas disparu
on a fait j'ai regardé un petit peu
pendant pendant l'interview tous les
sujets qu'on avait fait sur la santé
mentale en
2019-2020-2021 2022 2023 donc c'est
vraiment un sujet récurrent qu'on traite
beaucoup avec il a rappelé le manque de
psychologue les forfaits psychologues
qu'il avait
qui était offert le manque de poste en
psychiatrie avait mes tout en rappelant
qu'évidemment on va pas former des
psychiatres en 5 minutes et que c'est
assez voilà c'est assez assez complexe
mais oui un peu étonné de voir que la
santé mentale a été le premier sujet
abordé on sait que ça aurait été par
exemple pas les abaya ou la
précarité étudiante avec l'inflation
donc voilà pour ménager aussi le
suspense
je salue Aviel et Nox qui nous sont dans
le chat n'hésitez pas à nous poser vos
questions on y répond comme d'habitude
Nox qui nous non si on a le droit
d'utiliser son contenu le contenu du
cours des cryptes non nous n'allons pas
prendre son contenu nous avons nos
images d'Emmanuel Macron avec pavé
l'ancien ministre de l'Éducation lors de
visite lors d'un des dans des écoles
que on vous diffuse donc c'était le
premier sujet sur la santé mentale
ensuite il y a un deuxième sujet qui
n'était pas sur l'éducation en tant que
tel mais qui est un sujet qui tient à
cœur les jeunes c'est la crise
écologique oui parce que c'est vraiment
le premier sujet de préoccupation des
jeunes même devant le chômage toutes les
études le monde les sondages sont fait
régulièrement l'écologie et notamment la
crise climatique inquiète inquiète
vraiment les jeunes
certains soufflent même déco anxiété
donc c'est vraiment sujet très très
important et de voir que c'était traité
en deuxième position ça m'étonne pas du
tout donc c'est vrai que ça peut ça peut
vous étonner mais moi pas parce que
c'est vraiment tous les sondages on voit
que c'est vraiment le premier sujet de
préoccupation donc et puis on le voit
aussi chez les étudiants avec de
nombreuses grandes écoles qui sont ou
des étudiants on les appelle les
bifurquer qui décident de vraiment de
tout plaquer de de alors on n'est pas on
n'est plus comme dans les années 70 à
partir dans une ferme en Corrèze mais
presque c'est à dire vraiment de se dire
l'école qui m'a formé alors comme je
suis pas gros par exemple on a eu ça à
HC on a eu ça on a eu récemment encore
des étudiants de centrales un étudiant
centrale même qui a décidé de de
démissionner parce que ces étudiants
trouvent que les écoles ne prennent pas
assez au sérieux le problème climatique
la crise climatique donc le fait qu'il
est abordé ça je pense que ça c'était
pas étonnant oui c'était pas étonnant et
ça a été quelque chose qui a été
longuement dont ils ont longuement parlé
en parlant des transports en parlant de
de la réponse de la France c'était un
sujet assez comment dire assez globale
on va dire Oui puis on a vu que on
aurait peut-être un comme en Allemagne
un passe-temps enfin en tout cas le
sujet est en discussion auprès des
régions pour les vous savez les terres
régionaux pour offrir la gratuité pour
les jeunes alors bon pour l'instant oui
mais parce qu'il faut l'accord
évidemment des régions en question les
transports c'est une compétence
régionale et qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
en Allemagne en fait en Allemagne on a
le on a eu un pass au mois pour se
dépasser en gros dans leur TER hein
c'est pas encore le TGV gratuit donc
mais c'est vrai que la discussion enfin
l'interview portait beaucoup sur les
transports sur le fait que le kérosène
n'est pas taxé ça c'est on entend
beaucoup les jeunes le dire pourquoi
le quinzaine n'est pas taxé alors il a
rappelé que bah évidemment
il a supprimé des des vols nationaux de
moins de 2 heures enfin de cours mais
que
évidemment les compagnies aériennes
c'était un système concurrentiel
contrairement au train et que il pouvait
pas taxer le kérosène comme ça donc
c'est simple la raison pour laquelle
c'était moins cher et aussi c'est parce
que il y a beaucoup de concurrence dans
la nature qui n'a pas dans le train il a
aussi dit sur le sur la joue il a dit
bah oui mais Airbus ceux qui produisent
le plus d'avion bah ils sont français
donc c'est un peu compliqué pour moi
d'être contre l'avion on peut le dire
nous qui sommes dans un journal qui
appartient au groupe d'assaut c'est vrai
que
les l'aéronautique c'est un secteur
phare en France en fait et ça amène
beaucoup d'emplois donc c'est pas c'est
c'est voilà il y a aussi ça qui rentre
en jeu mais oui il a beaucoup il a parlé
très longuement un des transports mais
parce que c'est un sujet qui revient
beaucoup dans la bouche des jeunes on
envoie de plus en plus qui ne veulent
plus prendre l'avion pour les langues
qui reprochent même à leurs parents mais
pourquoi tu
c'est vraiment un sujet très fort alors
que je pensais pas autant en fait et
c'est donc là il a il a vraiment il
était dans le mille sur des sujets qui
qui importe aux jeunes on a on a Pauline
qui l'a précarité a bien été abordé sur
la fin par rapport aux augmentations oui
on va y revenir un peu plus tard on va
dérouler un peu les de ce dont il a
parlé il y a un sujet forcément aussi
sur le sur les rythmes scolaires il a
parlé de à l'école parce que dans une
interview Emmanuel Macron avait dit que
il faut faire revenir en fait les élèves
plutôt à l'école pour pas
leur oui l'injustice du fait que bah oui
il y a des enfants qui partent qui
profitent des vacances pour aller en
Angleterre apprendre l'anglais etc ou
faire des choses intelligentes avec
leurs parents et puis il y en a d'autres
bah qui restent dans leur quartier et
qui finalement arrive à la rentrée avec
du retard mais ce qui est intéressant
surtout c'est le fait de voir que il est
la possibilité enfin il est il envisage
la possibilité de changer complètement
le rythme scolaire il a rappelé par
exemple que à son époque on a vécu une
semaine de vacances que les petites
vacances là c'était tout ça par exemple
c'était une semaine et pas 15 jours donc
et puis prenant l'exemple sur d'autres
pays le fait de de d'avoir des
demi-journées de classe c'est-à-dire le
matin d'avoir classe et puis
l'après-midi de faire autre chose du
sport un peu comme ce qui se passe
en Allemagne par exemple donc ça c'est
des des questions qui voilà auxquels
évidemment c'est pas si simple de mettre
en place mais en tout cas d'avoir plus
de jours travaillés mais moins longtemps
parce qu'en fait ce qui se passe c'est
qu'en France on a des grosses journées
de cours avec des élèves qui sortent à
17h voir 18h et sur de très peu de jours
donc ce qui fait c'est assez fatigant
bah un peu comme les salariés parce
qu'on a beaucoup de vacances et donc on
a des journées beaucoup plus longues
dans certains pays étrangers en fait et
donc c'est fatiguant pour les élèves et
puis c'est pas très efficace donc mais
après c'est aussi un système qui
pratique pour les parents parce que ils
n'ont pas les faire garder donc il
faudrait que le l'après-midi consacré au
sport par exemple que ce soit pris en
charge oui voilà parler par lesquels il
a parlé justement il a fait un grand
plaidoyer finalement pour le pour le
sport à l'école justement ah oui avec
une heure de sport par collège et à
l'école primaire pour l'instant il y a
une demi-heure pour l'école primaire là
ce serait une heure de sport par jour
oui c'est c'est assez conséquent on se
dit et
je risque mais en fait où est-ce qu'on
va trouver finalement tout ce temps et
bien dit non mais avec mon avec ma façon
de voir les choses il y aura le temps
pour tout et donc pour cette heure de
sport que c'est vraiment
une concentration on voit dans les
écoles asiatiques par exemple on voit
les les enfants commencés par du sport
avant de commencer à
travailler donc évidemment le sport est
très bénéfique pour la concentration et
permet de mieux travailler
après en termes d'organisation
il va falloir peut-être trouver
évidemment ses profs de sport ou
peut-être aux primaires les faire faire
par les par les par les professeurs des
écoles les instituteurs donc mais c'est
intéressant en tout cas oui parce qu'il
y a aussi alors sur les professeurs mais
arriver à avoir on va parler de ce sujet
maintenant c'est le manque d'enseignants
dans les dans les
collèges dans les dans les écoles
primaires comment faire pour avoir un
élève un enseignant devant chaque élève
tous les jours là il a parlé beaucoup
d'absentéisme de remplacement mais il a
pas parlé par exemple ou alors ça m'a
échappé il a pas parlé de du problème de
d'attractivité de l'enseignement oui
j'ai pas parlé un peu de de de la
valorisation des enseignants mais s'ils
font des remplacements pas forcément sur
le salaire global
très important alors à part sur la
partie salaire bien sûr parce que
évidemment sur le fait de revaloriser
les salaires mais c'est vrai que c'est
un là on était sur le rythme scolaire
c'est un peu différent mais mais oui sur
le fait de d'attirer des enseignants
vers ce métier et peut-être que l'idée
justement c'est de de casser un peu le
rythme de faire des demi-journées plutôt
que des journées complètes pour
justement peut-être rendre l'école plus
attractive pour les pour les enseignants
et puis j'ai remarqué qu'il regardait
beaucoup les exemples étrangers il a
parlé la Finlande
alors la Finlande est un peu un peu
décroché ces dernières années on n'est
pas aussi bien qu'avant mais bon après
si on regarde du côté des pays
asiatiques qui sont qui ont les
meilleurs scores ils travaillent
beaucoup beaucoup mais oui il compare
beaucoup alors c'est vrai que 2023 en
décembre si mes souvenirs sont bons on
va avoir le nouveau testa pizza le CDE
qui va arriver donc c'est vrai
pas très bon non plus je pense pas que
ou alors ça
à mon avis on va être pas très bien noté
donc je pense c'est l'idée aussi de
prendre l'exemple sur d'autres pays qui
marche bien ce qui a des pays qui
marchent bien qui ne dépensent pas
forcément plus d'argent dans l'école
mais qui ont de meilleurs résultats
scolaire donc l'idée c'est peut-être
aussi de d'explorer des nouvelles pistes
donc un nouveau rythme avec plus de
jours d'école moins de vacances mais
mais des journées d'école plus courtes
avec pourquoi pas une demi-journée
d'école et une autre demi-journée avec
plus de sport et plus d'activités
culturelles il a parlé aussi
effectivement alors nouveau rythme et
aussi peut-être nouveaux habits pour
pour la rentrée avec cette question de
l'uniforme qui revient aussi dont on lui
a posé aussi cette question là
l'uniforme est-ce qu'il était pour ou
quoi
en rappelant bien sûr qu'il faut une
tenue correcte il a
se décrit plus à parler de des Crop top
enfin des problèmes de décence à l'école
et il a bien il a fait le parallèle
quand même même s'il le dit même s'il
dit qu'il n'a pas fait le parallèle il a
fait le parallèle quand même avec Samuel
Paty avec les attentats en rappelant que
bah il fallait pas mettre le la
poussière sous le tapis et que les
problèmes de laïcité avaient quand même
provoqué des violences dans le pays très
graves et donc
ça ne m'étonne pas parce que
toute ce nouveau règlement avec la Baya
c'est aussi l'idée de rassurer les
enseignants de donner un cadre parce que
les enseignants ont évidemment
traumatisés par
l'assassimat ça mêle pas les Français
ont été traumatisés dans leur général
par les émeutres dernièrement et donc
l'idée c'était de rassurer tout le monde
en disant on vous donne un cadre
finalement vous aurez vous n'aurez pas à
subir les pressions de la part des
familles etc donc ça il a rappelé ça
concernant c'est vrai que alors moi ça
me fait rire parce que l'uniforme c'est
vraiment un sujet qui revient dans notre
jargon on appelle ça un marronnier
exactement
avec beaucoup de ministres qui tousse
promettaient des expérimentations avec
l'uniforme
en fait c'est toujours ce message de
fermeté qu'on a envie de donner à la
rentrée et puis finalement quelques mois
après
un an après on en parle plus du tout
donc moi j'aimerais bien voir de mon
vivant une expérimentation avec
l'uniforme non mais elle parce que là
c'est vraiment l'arlésienne
avec la Légion d'Honneur les lycées
militaires on a fait il y a une émission
bien sûr de Paris d'école sur le Figaro
TV sur l'uniforme on voit le
Saint-Jean de Passy qui a instauré
l'uniforme depuis quelques années donc
il y a eu déjà des expérimentations donc
on a plein d'exemples à donner mais mais
c'est vrai que normalement Gabriel Attal
a dit que à l'automne on aurait des
expérimentations et pour l'instant j'ai
vu que voilà j'ai vu que bon la ville il
y avait que la ville de de Robert Ménard
et de la ville de Béziers qui avait
décidé évidemment qu'elle était pour
mais sinon j'en vois pas trop donc c'est
un peu l'arlésienne pour moi le uniforme
je veux le je veux voilà
je veux toucher pour avant d'être sûr
on verra donc à l'automne autre sujet
qui a été après c'était le le
harcèlement à l'école
le journaliste lui a posé la question on
lui rappelant les faits divers demandant
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire et il a eu
une annonce
avec une prochaine loi
pourquoi les les harceleurs pour être
banni des réseaux sociaux pendant 6 mois
par exemple
donc
pourquoi pas après tout aujourd'hui on a
la plateforme phare qui permet de
signaler les le harcèlement mais c'est
vrai que honnêtement moi qui fait un
livre sur le harcèlement scolaire il y a
quelques années donc j'ai vu un peu la
situation évoluer avec beaucoup de faits
divers depuis quand j'ai écrit ce livre
on parlait de Jonathan destin et c'était
déjà épouvantable mais depuis il y en a
eu des dizaines d'autres avec à chaque
fois des élèves des jeunes des enfants
même qui sont qui sont malheureusement
suicidés donc il a rappelé l'affaire de
la Lindsay donc et on voit que malgré
tout franchement la plateforme c'est
quand même assez efficace il y a eu
beaucoup beaucoup de mesures par rapport
au moment où j'ai écrit Steve et
aujourd'hui a beaucoup changé la
dernièrement on a eu l'annonce que les
harceleurs pourront être bannis de
l'école
pour être renvoyé de l'école et pas le
harceler qui partent voilà parce que
jusqu'à présent bah l'école disait à la
famille écoutez enlever votre enfant
c'est trop dangereux pour lui ça va pas
on l'enlève et désormais ben ce sera au
harceleur de de quitter l'école donc
c'est très nouveau
mais là le fait d'être banni des réseaux
sociaux c'est encore
décrit plus à demander est-ce que ce
sera aussi pour des harceleurs mais en
dehors de de l'école enfin des
harceleurs en général il a dit oui ce
serait ça concernerait tous les
harceleurs et donc
les réseaux sociaux parce qu'ils ont dit
que si le réseau social n'est pas en
capacité de vraiment bannir la personne
bien l'amende sera pour lui ça se fasse
aussi
la liberté quand même voilà que ce soit
vraiment du harcèlement mais mais bon on
attend de voir il y a sans doute des
accords qui sont peut-être en train en
discussion avec des avec les les réseaux
sociaux parce que on les a beaucoup
accusés quand même d'être complice de
ces
notamment pour la faire de l'INSEP parce
que c'était une vidéo qui circulait sur
à l'époque et de voilà d'être assez
inactif qui est faux puisque ils ont
quand même pas mal évolué mais c'est
vrai que les enfants aujourd'hui ont des
téléphones portables de plus en plus
jeunes le harcèlement ne s'arrête pas
comme avant après l'école il peut
continuer justement les boucles de
discussion et sur Emmanuel Macron a
rappelé que c'est pas uniquement sur les
réseaux sociaux ça peut être des boucles
WhatsApp ou finalement on n'a pas
tellement accès donc avec des messages
cryptés
mais c'est vrai que là c'était sur Tik
Tok et évidemment ces réseaux sociaux
ont une responsabilité donc je vois que
oui puis on voit qu'on sait aussi que
Brigitte Macron est très très
le ministre je me rappelle que enfin le
ministre papendaï avait reçu la famille
de Lindsay et la famille de laisser
avait dit oui le ministre n'a pas du
tout été très étonnés
je pense est beaucoup plus
et très bon c'est une ancienne
enseignante aussi une mère de famille
qui était professeur de français pendant
des années dans une école privée donc je
pense que elle a les mots aussi pour
parler aux parents quoi effectivement
non
l'éducation a été enseignant aussi hein
du du harcèlement scolaire il y a eu un
sujet parcoursup aussi puisque c'est
normalement chacun devrait avoir son
affectation sur parcoursup mais c'est a
priori pas encore satisfaire il a
rappelé qu'il y avait très peu beaucoup
moins de alors
1300 j'ai pu j'ai bien noté je crois que
ça a été comme ça c'est sans de moins
que le que le que l'an dernier il s'est
un peu félicité de ça aussi voilà il
faut rappeler que parcoursup c'est pas
terminé au mois de juillet comme on
pourrait le penser en fait il y a une
procédure complémentaire qui se termine
mi-septembre d'accord donc en fait il va
bientôt se terminer donc il y a toujours
des jeunes qui peuvent trouver une place
d'ailleurs si vous n'avez toujours pas
trouvé de place sur
sur le moment et donc chaque année à
cette époque on sait combien de
personnes sont restées sur le carreau
mais honnêtement c'est vrai ce qu'il dit
c'est à dire que il y a beaucoup de gens
aussi le peu de gens qui restent il y a
beaucoup de gens ont réorientation qui
ont pas forcément le bon bac ils
viennent de bac pro et beaucoup beaucoup
de réorientation donc et puis il y a le
rectorat qui est là qui honnêtement ça
ça s'est beaucoup amélioré par contre il
était un peu plus bas que sur un autre
système là c'est vraiment qui par contre
il est vraiment au cours d'amélioration
et et c'est le site mon Master vous
posez une colle j'ai pas les chiffres
c'est vrai que là par contre si
parcoursup c'est beaucoup amélioré quoi
qu'on en dise
mon Master alors ça a commencé cette
année vraiment avec le site là vraiment
énormément de problèmes c'est il y a eu
beaucoup de bugs sur le site et là c'est
vrai que c'était une colle pour bon il
peut pas non plus c'est pas le non plus
ministre de l'éducation nationale même
si vous avez un peu l'impression que
c'est que vous vous posez aussi c'est
parce que bon il est quand même
président de la République donc
j'imagine qu'il a d'autres chats
fouetter que de gérer les problèmes de
mon Master
on espère pour lui mais en tout cas
c'est vrai que le site mon Master là
cette année ça c'est pas très bien passé
et l'année prochaine il est prévu qui
est une procédure complémentaire comme
le site parcoursup c'est à dire où les
facs mettent leur place vacances et on
puisse postuler jusqu'à mi-septembre
comme sur parcours oui parce que la
question qui a été posée aussi c'est
est-ce que il y a assez de moyens de
l'université pour accueillir tous les
élèves euh
c'est c'est ce qu'on peut c'est quelque
chose qui a déposé Emmanuel Macron oui
alors
Hugo décrypte a dit Hugo a dit bah oui
mais elle a il y a un problème c'est que
il y a une sélection qui ne dit pas son
nom sur parcoursup et cetera
Emmanuel Macron alors on va regarder ça
je pense demain parce que ce soir un peu
tard mais on regardera assez rapidement
sur le Figaro étudiant c'est vrai parler
des 50% des élèves de première année de
licence qui ne vont pas à l'examen et
pour lui c'est un gros problème donc ça
veut dire qu'il y a beaucoup de gens qui
vont à la fac mais qui ne souhaite même
pas poursuivre alors il y a quand même
le problème j'aime bien quand même le
problème de ceux qui s'inscrivent à la
fac juste pour pour avoir leur bourse
mais c'est pas tout le monde bien sûr
et puis à certains qui se sont trompés
carrément d'orientation et comme il a
dit comme le président a dit il a
rappelé que il y en a beaucoup qui
allait à l'université mais finalement
qui n'était pas fait pour aller à
l'université et qui s'en rend compte
après qui sont en échec scolaire donc
voilà donc c'était
c'était assez intéressant mais c'est
quand même assez étonnant de voir je
suis désolé mais de voir un président de
la République
s'intéressait de façon aussi précise à
la au rythme scolaire on avait
l'impression que vraiment sur la rentrée
scolaire il avait appris par coeur Hugo
lui propose pas tellement de sur la
rentrée scolaire et lui il déroule le
truc genre vous avez oublié de me poser
des questions sur la rentrée moi je vais
vous le dérouler je vais vous donner
toutes les mesures que je vais faire je
vais vous expliquer
les questions sur les étudiants et non
non on a eu les tests en cm enfin je
sais pas quoi en primaire et cetera de
façon à mon avis tellement précise que
je me suis dit mais enfin c'est quand
même plutôt ministre de me parler tout
ça quoi effectivement il prend un peu sa
place alors on sait qu'il a fait
l'éducation un grand sujet pour son
donc aujourd'hui vraiment il prend toute
la place finalement
en étant bon on peut donner les grandes
lignes mais on n'est pas forcé de
rentrer dans les plus grands détails sur
bon et quand même sur mon Master où il
est un peu séché heureusement ça sera du
travail à la mise de l'enseignement
supérieur
pour préciser tout ça mais l'éducation
est au taquet ça c'est sûr que c'était
assez
assez surprenant effectivement et alors
dernière question que je vais vous poser
et c'est aussi la dernière question qui
a été posée enfin l'une des dernières
questions et sur la précarité étudiante
qui finalement un sujet qui est arrivé
assez tard alors que dans l'entretien
alors que justement il y a de plus en
plus d'étudiants qui ont recours
aujourd'hui à alimentaire et qui sont de
plus en plus touchés par la précarité
oui j'étais étonné parce que je pensais
que il allait aborder ça au début au
moins un peu c'est quand même un sujet
important et surtout que la chaîne enfin
la chaîne du côté s'adresse aux jeunes
et il a rappelé alors moi il y a quelque
chose qui m'a frappé mais je suis désolé
c'est quand même c'est ma spécialité
l'entreprise forcément bon il a rappelé
que l'éducation en France était gratuite
c'était pas le cas à l'étranger que
évidemment c'était dur pour les
étudiants mais il y a quand même 25 1/4
des élèves qui étaient boursiers qui ne
payaient pas du tout leur fraise
scolarité et bon ça c'est vrai mais il a
parlé des écoles de commerce et
d'ingénieurs il était pour l'ouverture
de formation courte
dans les petites villes de où la vie
justement le coût de la vie n'était pas
cher en fait donc là c'est un sujet donc
ça veut dire par exemple alors j'ai
pensé bien sûr au sujet des Bachelor
beaucoup d'écoles de commerce et
d'ingénieurs ces dernières années ont
ouvert des bac + 3
avant elle faisait que des programmes
grandes écoles
techniques les écoles de commerce et
tout ça mais aujourd'hui elles ont une
myriade de de diplôme en trois ans et il
en a parlé en disant que ben il aimerait
bien que ces écoles développent encore
plus de diplôme en trois ans
professionnel pour finalement qu'on
arrive plus pour que plus de villes ou
le coût de la vie le loyer moins cher
j'ai trouvé ça étonnant qui parle de ça
parce que ça veut dire que
il connaît bien le sujet parce que bon
ben moi je connais les Bachelor mais
peut-être que les auditeurs
étudiant
parce que c'est vrai que c'est un
phénomènes qui a pris de l'ampleur ces
dernières années
même Polytechnique à un Bachelor quand
même c'est assez sidérant le SCP les
secs enfin les plus grandes écoles ont
des formations en trois ans et puis
maintenant il y a des tas d'école de
commerce d'ingénieurs ce qui développent
plein de comme ça de formation en deux
trois ans pour dans des petites villes
et là pour lui c'était la solution pour
résoudre le problème de la du coup la
vie étudiante parce que si évidemment on
habite une petite ville moins chère ce
sera plus facile de voilà de de trouver
un logement parler d'un sujet par contre
il m'aurait intéressé aussi c'est le
problème de la du logement étudiant qui
est vraiment un énorme problème en cette
rentrée oui effectivement dans cette île
à Paris
dans des villes où le marché est très
tendu et il y a une crise de
l'immobilier en ce moment en France
alors c'est chaque année mais cette
année c'est vraiment particulier avec la
hausse des taux les jeunes
professionnels ne peuvent plus acheter
et du coup ils occupent les studios
loués et les libèrent pas pour les
étudiants et c'est un vrai sujet
particulièrement stadé donc ça aurait
été bien de qu'il en parle mais bon
voilà c'était c'était quand même très
dense sur ces sur ces deux heures il a
dit qu'il pouvait pas parler de tout
Sophie je crois qu'on a fait le tour je
pense de tout ce qu'il a dit pendant ces
deux heures on a été un peu plus rapide
que lui figure merci en tout cas d'avoir
été avec nous merci à vous dans notre du
Figaro d'avoir été nombreux à nous
suivre et moi je vous dis je vous
souhaite une bonne soirée sur le site du
Figaro et sur notre chaîne YouTube